all right finally tonight I want to wish
a happy belated International intern day
to the Ingram angles College associates
David Vega and Caroline Leary both join
me now uh David where are you from and
what's up next for you yeah hi first I'd
like to say hello to my parents uh I
live in Cambridge Massachusetts uh And
in regards to the internship I've most
enjoyed how it's structured I like
having you know seven hours you put your
work into something and then for the
last hour you get to see all of your
effort on screen on TV well you've done
a great job from what I hear and yeah
I'm glad you've made it what about you
where are you from and uh what are you
gonna do next I'm from Connecticut and
next up for me is just back to school
back to college I'm studying abroad in
the fall and in regards to the
internship I mean it's very difficult to
choose what I love most but it's really
cool being immersed into the TV you know
world and especially working with the
lovely anger mangle team that's good
that's good all right Dave and Caroline
thanks for Hardware good luck to you and
we can't forget the angles former intern
Gabriel vazi who's now works on she
works on the show she graduated works on
the show thanks Gabby hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else